what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
mcu and yesterday many of you might have
stumbled across
a leaked set video for black panther 2
wakanda forever and not just this leaked
set video but also a leaked
photo of the set of black panther 2 that
gives us some pretty dang good evidence
that
namor and atlantis are indeed going to
be in black panther 2
which of course we'll talk about it's
obviously very very
exciting news production for black
panther 2 has begun
and of course as production for
something starts
leaks get out this video is a perfect
example
side note it's also pretty hilarious how
this person is simply taking this video
in front of
all of these people and nobody said
anything like put your phone away you
can't have that here but now it's out
and it is what it is
however a lot of people have actually
misunderstood the significance of this
leaked video
yes this room right here was previously
the throne room in the black panther
film however there
are some indications that lead us to
believe that it
might not actually be the throne room
anymore
now it actually looks like a place that
they could be dedicating
to t'challa it does indeed look like in
the marvel universe black panther is
going to be
dead this has been said before but now
it looks pretty official as we take a
look at this set
and there's actually some extremely
interesting things written on some of
these columns in wakandan and don't
worry i'll break
everything down that you need to know
including some more evidence that
namor the submariner and atlantis just
might show up in black panther 2 wakanda
forever
so if you love the mcu and want to stay
up to date on everything including black
panther 2 wakanda forever be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
so this video does indeed show the
throne room from the very first black
panther film
however there are some really really big
differences here
mainly the columns on the walls that
have wakandan writing on them
don't know what they mean don't worry
the internet's got you there was one
eagle-eyed fan out there who noticed
that the writing on these columns
actually was talking about t'challa and
the twitter account creamer scream
actually translated the text and then
other people including the reddit user
the armored avenger
and many others after actually double
checked the translation to make sure
that
it was indeed accurate and they all say
the same thing
it is right and here's what they say
rest in power
king t'challa our hero twas an honor
wakanda forever obviously this is very
touching they're paying tribute to
t'challa and of course in the same way
they are paying tribute to
chadwick boseman and i have no doubt
that marvel is going to do
a very very awesome tribute to chadwick
boseman either before
or after the movie and we know that the
movie itself is going to pay tribute to
chadwick
ryan coogler the director kevin feige
the president of marvel studios and
other cast members have made that very
obvious
they've all stated plenty of times that
the script does justice and honor to
chadwick's legacy and i have no doubt
that that's what's going to happen
now as touching as this is it actually
has a pretty big reveal here
it says rest in power t'challa not
chadwick boseman
but t'challa meaning that king t'challa
the black panther
is indeed going to be dead in this film
are we going to see him
die on screen i really doubt it and some
people from marvel have spoken up and
said that they don't really want to do a
cgi chadwick bozeman for
any of the scenes many people are
wondering how exactly they're going to
be tackling this
the death of t'challa are they really
going to mention it are they going to
have
a funeral is he going to be alive when
the movie starts off
but he dies off screen somehow we don't
really know but it does sound like
marvel has figured out the best way to
do this the most
proper way to do this by paying respect
to chadwick boseman
so i have no doubt that they'll handle
it the right way and also make black
panther a truly epic film and it looks
like it truly is shaping up that way
because today we have some pretty solid
evidence that
namor is going to be a part of black
panther 2. this has been rumored for a
while now
the rumors and reports actually started
before chadwick passed away and
everybody was wondering if this was
still going to be the game plan
after his passing wakanda and atlantis
have
a pretty big history at being at war
with one another
and it was said that we were going to
explore this war or this tension between
the two civilizations in black panther
ii
but today we have a leaked photo that
shows us that this still probably is the
case
somebody who was working on or at least
i hope they're still working on it after
sharing this photo because who knows
that they got in trouble but somebody
who was working on the black panther 2
set with the username cine8 posted this
photo to
instagram it's of a huge water tank to
shoot underwater scenes and the caption
says doing a little diving in the black
panther tank today
let's have some fun so why would black
panther 2
have a huge tank to shoot underwater
scenes well when you have a character
like namor who lives in an underwater
ancient lost civilization you probably
need to shoot some underwater scenes
this is pretty good evidence right here
that marvel is still planning on going
forward with the name more slash
atlantis story arc that they had before
for black panther 2 which isn't that
surprising because they have been given
us
little easter eggs for neymar throughout
the mcu even though they didn't have the
rights to use him at the time
in iron man 2 we had the namor easter
egg when nick fury and tony stark were
talking in the background we could see a
map
with some pin locations one of those is
wakanda and the other one
is off of africa in the middle of the
ocean in the middle of
the atlantic ocean of course there's
really only one thing that shield could
be monitoring in the middle of the
atlantic ocean especially if you
consider that they were monitoring
other beings that could be in the
avengers so that is definitely namor
then in avengers in-game okoye mentioned
to natasha that there was an underwater
earthquake
off the coast of africa natasha wanted
to check into it but okoye said
it's an underwater earthquake we handle
it by not handling it now you could have
shrugged this off but when the writers
were asked about this if it was
indeed a name or easter egg they said
sometimes you plant seeds
sometimes they grow basically confirming
yeah that's namor it could possibly have
even been
an attack of the atlanteans on the
wakandans after all this was during the
five year gap where it seemed like
things were
kind of chaotic unless you were one of
the flax smashers in which case you
actually enjoyed the five year gap where
half of the people were gone
however prince t'challa did get dusted
away in the snap and perhaps maybe
name or didn't or whoever is in charge
of atlantis at the time and perhaps they
saw that as the perfect opportunity to
attack wakanda perhaps black panther 2
could deal with some of that aftermath
now ultimately we know that name war
will eventually go on to become
somewhat of a good person he'll go on to
become a hero in the mcu
and there have also been casting reports
that his cousin namora
and possibly another villain have been
cast for this film as well
which means it might be kind of like a
batman vs superman type of thing
godzilla vs kong where at first they
fight but then they get a common enemy
come together to defeat that enemy we
know how the story goes however i will
give credit to marvel when they did
civil war they did not have them unite
at the end
it ended with pretty much cap winning
and the avengers falling apart however
that was definitely to
set up the events of infinity war so i
think black panther 2
if namor truly is in the movie which it
seems like at this point we have a ton
of evidence that says
yes he will be i think it'll be a good
combination of captain america civil war
and batman vs superman
but either way it's exciting because
neymar is actually a mutant
so if he truly is coming which it really
does seem like he is
that means more mutants are coming to
the mcu which of course
is what we are all waiting for until we
get that x-men film
but in the meantime let me know what you
think about this news in the comments
down below the tribute to king t'challa
in black panther 2 and the approach
of namor don't forget to subscribe and
click the notification bell if you want
to stay up to date on all things mcu
don't forget to like the video and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof